[Musica]
tu come ti chiami
Sì Giulia Giulia sei un egoista
E tu invece col telefono in mano Come ti
chiami
come
Roberta Anche tu lo sei
noi tutti in realtà siamo degli egoisti
ma non lo siamo abbastanza
E ora mi spiego meglio perché
chiaramente non vi abbiamo fatto venire
qui per insultarvi facciamo un esempio
immaginiamo noi di essere un condominio
ognuno di noi naturalmente si occupa
della propria abitazione Quindi cosa
fareste Ognuno cerca di tenerla pulita
in ordine per raccogliere ospiti come è
normale che sia o quasi
ma
del condominio
chi se ne occupa
ed è strano perché comunque prima di
arrivare in casa dovete per forza
passare da lì
e stendiamo adesso questo concetto a
livello Urbano cittadino e ci possiamo
rendere conto che le prime vere fratture
nella nostra società sono proprio lì nei
borghi nelle periferie nelle zone
industriali e nei casi peggiori anche
nei centri cittadini
Ma io mi chiedo
Come possiamo rendere bella una frattura
Come possiamo guardare una cosa
oggettivamente brutta e dire che invece
affascinante come possiamo restituire
dignità a questi ultimi io questa a
questa domanda ho trovato risposta
nell'arte urbana mi sono calato giù
nelle più profonde fratture della nostra
civiltà e con la forza delle storie che
a me piace tanto raccontare ho trovato
il modo dovete sapere che se io fossi
nato cantante Certamente sarestano un
cantastorie e ho cercato sempre di
sviluppare la mia arte con questo
approccio ed è Grazie diciamo a questa
cosa che mi sono mi sono imbattuto a
delle realtà come Sant'Agata del bianco
è un piccolo Borgo della provincia di
Reggio Calabria che una volta era denso
e popoloso e che poi in realtà è rimasto
essere abitato
Allora cosa abbiamo fatto in questo
Borgo in realtà non abbiamo fatto altro
che prendere le storie che già
esistevano i personaggi che già avevano
popolato quel paese e l'abbiamo
raccontata in un percorso artistico E
allora A quel punto come potete anche
vedere Nella foto il borgo è tornato a
spendere di una nuova luce è tornato di
nuovo a rivivere ma non perché la gente
ha comprato le case ma semplicemente
perché è diventato una meta turistica
chiaramente non solo grazie all'arte ma
è diventata la metodoristica per
persone per vera alunni ecco per gente
che si era annoiata magari di andare la
domenica al centro commerciale o di
camminare nella via commerciale della
propria città
E allora capite che è molto semplice con
le storie fa rivivere un luogo ho visto
Appunto quindi storie popolari rivivere
rinascere E dell'esempio appunto della
gelsominaria di Archi questa a me piace
definirlo come esempio cardine del mio
modo di lavorare perché perché qui
abbiamo preso una storia che ha
caratterizzato la Sicilia ma meglio
ancora la provincia di Messina un
grandissimo territorio per tantissimi
secoli ha dato vita e lavoro e dignità a
tantissime donne e famiglie che
lavoravano all'interno dei campi dei
Gelsomini e che poi negli ultimi 50 anni
Erano state dimenticate per una
rivoluzione industriale alla fine E
allora capite in questo caso come una
semplice immagine abbia fatto riemergere
nella memoria delle persone Una storie
che in realtà non è neanche così antica
e vi dico che dopo questo dopo questa
chiamiamola così è capitata una cosa
molto bella
tantissime persone ma migliaia di
persone non facevano altro che scrivere
e tornare a raccontare ai propri nipoti
conoscenti a me contattandomi di come la
loro madre la loro nonna loro stessi
avessero lavorato nei campi di gelsomini
i fatti ho raccolto una testimonianza
molto bella di una donna col figlio che
hanno raccontato la stessa medesima
storia Ovvero quella del lavoro della
vita nei campi di gelsomini Ma da dove
prospettive diverse quelle del bambino e
quella è la madre che doveva andare dove
andare avanti la famiglia e allora anche
qui capite la potenza di un'immagine
come può rendere di nuovo dignità ad una
storia e far rivivere una storia e una
popolazione
ho visto anche
gente unirsi per raggiungere lo stesso
obiettivo ed è il caso di cannistra è un
piccolo borgo che addirittura era stato
dimenticato pure dalla propria
amministrazione comunale dal proprio
comune di appartenenza e mi piace sempre
raccontare che quando sono quando sono
arrivato in questo piccolo borgo ho
trovato già delle persone che la prima
domenica del mese invece di andare a
scroccare il biglietto gratis al museo
semplicemente si riuniva per pulire le
vie del proprio Paese piantare qualche
pianta e allora lì è bastato veramente
poco un piccolo innesto d'arte grazie
alla collaborazione di cittadini per far
diventare canistrano un posto di
aggregazione culturale per giovani
anziani curiosi per chiunque e infatti
sono stati tanti gli eventi come reading
come quello che vedete in foto è un
reading delle poesie di Camilleri perché
era appunto da poco avvenuta la sua
morte Allora dei ragazzi hanno deciso di
organizzare questo reading letterario
bellissimo e poi tante diciamo tante
altre manifestazioni di natura culturale
ecco vedete di questi esempi noi
fortunatamente siamo abbastanza pieni
poi questo vi sembra fantascienza ve lo
garantisco ho visto la realtà
industriali preoccuparsi per una volta
di avere il minor impatto visivo
possibile
ed è il caso di un progetto che vede in
questo caso la street art in una maniera
atipica ovvero itinerante viaggiante Ma
questo progetto ve lo voglio raccontare
in un altro modo ora immaginiamo di
essere la popolazione di un paese
afflitto da guerre e carestie e che
ognuno di noi l'unica cosa che ha visto
nella propria vita è sudore della
propria fronte per forze un pezzo di
pane e sicuramente tanti figli
ora immaginiamo che improvvisamente
arrivi dal nulla Un enorme container con
una cosa che generalmente non siete
abituati a vedere ovvero un disegno o un
opera d'arte a vostra discrezione e
immaginate che questa questa opera
arrivi in un punto apparentemente
desertico e si piazzì tra poi e il
vostro lavoro e l'incognita a un certo
punto vi rendete conto Pure che questa
opera d'arte In realtà all'interno è
un'officina che probabilmente garantirà
i vostri figli un futuro un po' migliore
rispetto a quello che avete avuto voi
Ecco in questo caso L'arte o l'arte
urbana o l'arte itinerante Che ruolo ha
in questo caso crea una crepa Ma è una
crepa dal quale sicuramente può
fuoriuscire luce e non fango
ecco
in queste in queste cose io mi torna in
mente una teoria la teoria della
finestra rotta Ovvero quella in cui se
tu vivi in un contesto degradato e più
probabile scientificamente che tu
contribuisca a degradarlo con ulteriori
attivanti vandalici piuttosto che
impegnarti e riqualificarlo
ma a questo punto se ci pensiamo
l'arte urbana Che ruolo potrebbe avere
in questo caso magari quella finestra
rotta è la lente dell'occhiale di un
uomo disegnato sul muro e a quel punto
diciamo il passante il turista o
l'abitante non vedrà tanto più una
finestra rotta ma vedrà un'idea uno
spunto Uno scorcio fotografico Ed è
proprio per questo motivo che nel corso
degli anni sono nati i cosiddetti street
art Hunter ovvero i cacciatori di street
art che non è in questo caso un termine
brutto ma sono semplicemente persone
estremamente curiose che vanno nei
luoghi visitati dalla street art e
documentano con delle foto e poi
semplicemente pubblicano sui social e
questo innesca un nuovo tipo di turismo
che è soltanto dedito all'arte
Ecco noi di questi esempi in Italia ne
abbiamo tanti mi viene in mente Napoli
con i quartieri spagnoli Ma anche in
Sicilia abbiamo Palermo con Ballarò La
Vucciria Catania Librino ma senza andare
troppo lontano andiamo sui Nebrodi che
qui nella nostra provincia e visitiamo
per un attimo Trivi Ecco Trivi è un
altro di quei Borghi che subisce la
sorte di tutti i nostri Borghi Ovvero lo
spopolamento Ma in questo caso perché è
stata importante la street art perché ha
avuto un ruolo di collaborazione con
l'archeologia
è strano è vero però questi questi due
mondi possono anche coesistere e vi
spiego perché quello che vedete in foto
è la bozza fatta dagli architetti del
Politecnico di Bari che me l'hanno
gentilmente concessa della necropoli che
è stata trovata a Trivi anticamente
chiamata a bacainon e che attualmente
diciamo è campagna di scavi archeologici
allora in quel caso a cosa è servita la
street art semplicemente
ad aiutare a raccontare la storia di un
popolo passato che aveva vissuto lì
aveva dato splendore a quelle colline
Ecco quindi
capite
qual è Quale ruolo può avere la street
art o comunque l'arte urbana in genere
io credo mi piace definirla in un modo o
l'arte urbana e vi spiego anche perché
poi piace così tanto anche a me io la
definisco democratica
durante la Big Generation i poeti
attribuivano l'aggettivo Democratico
alla bomba Diciamo che la bomba Era
democratica perché colpiva tutti
indistintamente Ecco facendole le dovute
differenze la street art è ugualmente
una bomba perché arriva a tutti
indistintamente Non devi far parte di un
Elite non devi pagare un biglietto
arriva a chi la ama e a chi non la ama
allo stesso tempo perché tu in una pausa
lavoro in una passeggiata giri l'angolo
e magari ti ritrovi davanti a un'opera
d'arte che può piacere o non può piacere
ma sicuramente li può regalare uno
spunto un'osservazione Ecco quindi il
ruolo della street art perché è stato
così incisivo nella rigenerazione urbana
dei Quartieri perché non fa altro che
caratterizzare un luogo un luogo in cui
le persone si possono riconoscere e
questo è importante perché condivisione
ecco
se noi fossimo più egoisti e così vi
spiego anche cosa volevo insegnare
all'inizio noi ci occuperemo
probabilmente della crepa che sta
inghiottendo la nostra splendida e ben
confezionata a casa anche solo per un
tornaconto personale alla fine non c'è
niente di male guardare volere il meglio
Perseo se anche gli altri ci guadagnano
in quello che state facendo non è
sbagliato e allora io mi chiedo in
questo caso Cosa succederebbe se noi
appunto fossimo egoisti in questo cosa
cosa potremmo fare come come potremmo
spingerci oltre e non lo sto dicendo
soltanto a voyagendomi contorni
inquisitore È una domanda che mi faccio
anch'io io come posso migliorare il
luogo in cui vivo la mia arte
La domanda è secondo me trova una
semplice risposta Io credo che
pretendendo di vivere tutti quanti in un
posto migliore cominceremo a pensare le
cose in fase di costruzione e non di
riparazione non quando già è troppo
tardi e Ma voi immaginate cosa potrebbe
voler dire inserire l'arte urbana ma in
ogni sua forma perché io ovviamente mi
occupo di muralismo ma non esiste
soltanto il moralismo cosa vorrebbe dire
includerlo all'interno delle fasi di
progettazione di piazze edifici pubblici
zona industriali perché no Io credo che
potremmo vivere tranquillamente in un
posto migliore un posto più piacevole
anche lavorare in un posto migliore e
non lo dico soltanto io in realtà ci
sono delle ricerche come Quella
pubblicata su start Magazine in cui il
69% degli intervistati Dei Lavoratori
hanno dichiarato di lavorare meglio in
un luogo
ricreativo anche artisticamente attivo
ma in realtà se ci pensiamo bene non
servono neanche queste percentuali è una
cosa così banale da essere intuitiva voi
preferireste vivere o lavorare in un
garage o nella Reggia di Caserta
Comunque
c'è da dire che L'arte in generale ha il
potere di cambiare le prospettive delle
cose anche la cosa più banale quella a
cui il vostro occhio ormai assuefatto
arriva un artista che vi Cambia la
prospettiva e quella cosa comincia a
splendere di una nuova luce
ora facciamo una scommessa
Scommettiamo che vi Cambia la
prospettiva di una cosa che conosciamo
così bene perché la natura ce l'ha data
fortunatamente meravigliosa abbondanza
da averlo visto in tutti i modi Forse
dipinto
hanno usato
nuotato
pescato
navigato
vi sfido e torno
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Grazie
[Musica]